we've got did we hear platform
flip-flops approaching oh yeah I'd like
to see a lawyer Hilary Duff and the cast
of Lizzie McGuire took to Instagram for
a virtual reunion we haven't opened
together in a very long time and they're
raising money for organizations
supporting those affected by the corona
virus pandemic we also wanted to ask if
you're in the position to be able to
donate any money then we have provided a
few links below to some of our favorite
charities and if not no problem thanks
for being here and hopefully you could
just help spread the word
and yes the cast can still sing the
show's theme song well kind of they even
managed to pull off a very entertaining
script reading of a classic Lizzie
McGuire episode
that's disgusting um mrs. McGuire
we're supposed to be adults so you
probably wanna shop alone if you're so
adult then you tell her I even see you
tell her this reunion is kind of
bittersweet considering it's the closest
we'll see you Lizzie McGuire again
anytime soon it feels very surreal to be
honest a reboot series for Disney Plus
was announced in August of 2019 and
Hilary Duff even began filming the show
earlier this year this means but
production has been on hold since
January after some public creative
differences between Hilary and Disney
the star later took to Instagram to
explain that she thought Hulu would be a
better platform for people to see an
adult Lizzie McGuire Hilary wrote was
incredibly excited to launch Lizzie on
d-plus and my passion remains however I
feel
huge responsibility to honor the fans
relationship with Lizzie who like me
grew up seeing themselves in her I'd be
doing a disservice to everyone by
limiting the realities of a 30 year olds
journey to live under the ceiling of a
PG rating back in November Hillary told
et what to expect from the planned
reboot my favorite thing growing up and
watching Lizzie was that she was a
little bit awkward and kind of going
through some real struggles now that
she's in her 30s what kind of struggles
do we see her go through can you answer
that yeah I think that was part of the
draw for me of coming back was like the
struggles that I feel of being a 30 year
old and obviously we're in very
different places I'm a mother I'm in a
serious relationship
and she has a lot of those things she
has gained a lot of confidence and she
has a really cool career and you know
she's still I think she's still going to
be faced with challenging things we're
in middle school those challenging
things seemed funny and simple but
relatable at the time and I think now in
your 30s it's gonna be the same way but
it's like slightly heavier slightly
bigger things to deal with like she
doesn't have kids yet and she you know
she there's some surprises in the first
episode that I also don't want to give
away but I think it's really gonna be
fun to go on on the journey with her at
30 and you know it's the same Lizzie but
she's an adult and I think for me that's
a little challenging shooting because I
have that muscle memory of that like
awkward frantic kind of teenager and so
making choices ran like they innovate
she wouldn't say that she's 30 she can't
do that now like it's it's definitely
fun and a little challenging and also so
familiar at the same time
[Music]